i don't think that radical islamic
doctrine
or its agenda is capable of defeating
western society it's just
militarily economically not
capable of doing that but if the west
implodes
that's going to come from the inside
in 1992 a 23 year old named ayan fled
kenya
for the netherlands after being forced
into an unwanted marriage and she took
political asylum under her grandfather's
last name
percy ali ayan was born in somalia where
at a young age her father who was a
leading figure in the somali revolution
was in prison
and her grandmother had a female genital
mutilation procedure common in islamic
culture performed on her
through childhood ayan was a devout
muslim in a muslim family
her father escaped prison in 1977 her
family ran to saudi arabia then ethiopia
and then kenya
after an escape of her own to the
netherlands ayan furthered her education
and even became a member of parliament
there her citizenship in the netherlands
was then jeopardized
which brought her to u.s shores in 2001
ion's muslim faith fell
when osama bin laden justified the
september 11th attacks with the koran
in 2002 she renounced her faith in islam
and she wrote her first book the sun
factory
the first of many from ion exposing the
oppression of women among muslims and
the need for islamic reformation
her newest book is prey immigration
islam and the erosion of women's rights
her writing and convictions have made
her the target of danger death threats
hatred at levels not experienced by just
about anyone else on planet earth they
can kill me
but they can't clearly figure out the
book exists she tells us
in today's episode about the most recent
risks from radical muslim men and how
the west must respond to this clash with
our own ideology
we'll also discuss what the left can
learn about confronting extremism from
the right
and if secularism is a viable principle
in a free and just society
[Music]
hey and welcome this is the ben shapiro
show sunday special this show is
sponsored by expressvpn don't like big
tech and the government spying on you
visit expressvpn.com
ben just a reminder we'll be doing some
bonus questions at the end with ion
hersey ali the only way to get access to
that part of the conversation is to
become a member
head on over to dailywire.com become a
member we'll have access to all of the
full conversations with every one
of our awesome guests ayan hersey ali
thanks so much for joining
the show ben thank you very much for
having me so
why don't we begin with the controversy
of the day so your book
prey has become quite controversial
because you make what seems to me a
relatively uncontroversial contention
which is that the failure of the west to
face up to the threat
of radical islamism is leading to
increase in
crime particularly predatory behavior
toward women in europe why is this such
a particularly controversial contention
everything about islam and immigration
and muslim immigration to europe is
controversial
even without the subject of this book it
always has been like that
uh after the terrorist attacks you know
from 9 11 2001
to this day these topics are very very
controversial
very much contested people who are
critical of
or who make a link between the ideology
of radical islam
and those who act on it they're accused
of islamophobia
of bigotry of all kinds so it's not
it's not something that started today
it's been around for a long time
so when it comes to radical islam a lot
of us use that term
what do you think is sort of the
breakdown in the islamic world between
people
who believe moderate things you know
reform islam
people believe in the values of the west
or at least believe that islam is
compatible with the values of the west
individual freedom and liberty
tolerance and diversity with regard to
religion versus radical islamic beliefs
intolerance of other religions
the need to dominate uh what do you
think the breakdown there is because
according to the the press and the west
obviously there are very very few
radical muslims and there are many many
moderate muslims what
you you lived in the muslim world
obviously you were brought up in the
muslim world what do you think the
actual breakdown
worldwide looks like i think in terms of
breakdown
i use the distinction between islam and
muslims
islam as a set of ideas and the religion
itself
but also the political aspects of that
religion
and i say that there is one islam but
there are different sets of muslims
there are 1.5 billion muslims in the
world
and there's one set that when they
invoke the prophet muhammad the founder
of islam
and the holy quran which is the holy
scripture of islam
they invoke events that took place in
mecca in the 7th century
and that is when the founder of islam
mohammed was going from door to door
preaching he wasn't using force
so i regard those muslims that subset of
muslims as mecca muslims
and then the prophet goes to medina and
he starts to wage war
and he starts to give people in medina
the choice
you either get rid of your gods and your
beliefs
and you come to islam or you lose your
head
and from medina onwards islam really
starts to expand
very very quickly and there are muslims
to this day
who invoke or when they invoke the
prophet muhammad
that's the time that they're referring
to when islam becomes a political tool
a military tool and an expansionist
imperial power
and those muslims i call that subset of
muslims i call them the medina muslims
and then you have now a small but
growing group
of people in the 21st century who are
saying let's reject
the teachings of medina and i call them
the modifiers some people call them the
reformers
uh i don't know i'm sure you've heard of
majid nawaz
he is a part of that group of people who
are trying to
reform or reject islam as a political
tool
they face accusations of heresy
they are very often threatened and left
unprotected
but as a development it's interesting
and i think they're gaining
some influence among the mecca muslims
so with regard to islam in the west and
particularly muslims living in
westernized countries what you talk
about in prey
is the high levels of crime particularly
targeting of women associated
with muslim refugees who are essentially
unvetted coming into europe
which branch of islam that you've
mentioned are these
folks coming from what is their belief
system and why does it clash so strongly
with the west
so ben the first thing i do in the book
is i really make it very clear that i'm
not referring to all
muslims and all muslim men as criminals
or as sex offenders against women
but yes there is a group of young men
who come from countries like syria
afghanistan
iraq somalia you name it and
they do engage in sexual offenses
against women in the public space and
it's now becoming something of an
epidemic in some of these countries
and yeah when they
um commit these offenses and some of
them are brought to
trial they speak of women with
contempt they don't necessarily invoke
religion but when some of the political
leaders and media leaders in europe
go and see imams and other religious
leaders and ask
either for an explanation or for help
with
trying to mitigate this problem some of
these imams say well
the women should be covered they
shouldn't be where they get into trouble
and uh you know you guys you shouldn't
be selling alcohol
and and then that becomes sort of
that sets the tone for
um these young men who are committing
the offenses
uh who think that it's not something
that they're doing wrong
it's the environment that should adjust
to their
to them ayaan in just one second i want
to ask you about your own personal
experience with islam with which
obviously
uh there's a very interesting history
there for those who have not heard it
we'll get to that in just one second
first
let's talk about protecting your online
safety and security have you ever
stopped to wonder why internet access is
so much cheaper these days than it used
to be
well it's because internet service
providers as in the companies that
provide you with your internet aren't
just making money off subscription fees
they're also making money from spying on
your internet activity and then selling
your history and data to big tech
companies
so what is the best way to make sure
that 100 of your data is encrypted
and that your isp can't get a hold of it
you guessed it expressvpn
expressvpn creates a secure tunnel
between all your devices and the
internet so everything you do online is
encrypted
it reroutes your connection through a
secure server and that blocks your isp
from seeing everything that you do
online
all they can see is that you're
connected to an expressvpn server
nothing beyond that
it's not just for your phone or computer
expressvpn works on all your devices it
works on your tablets
your smart tvs even your router so your
entire family can always stay protected
i cannot stress this enough expressvpn
is so simple to use you open up the app
you tap a button
that's the whole thing you know you
might think that it's safe to be on the
internet if you're using like incognito
mode
wrong you need a vpn your data is your
business protect it at expressvpn.com
visit expressvpn.com ben to get three
extra months of expressed vpn protection
for free that's expr essvpn.com to learn
more
so ayan i want to ask you for for those
who have not heard your life story
and and your origins story obviously you
had dealings with a lot of people who
believe
uh the the medina version of islam so
what is your personal experience with
islam and then leaving islam as you
move to the west when 2001 9 11 2001
when those terrorist attacks occurred in
new york and washington
a lot of us were trying to figure out
what exactly happened what motivated
these people and i had taken the
position
that they were motivated by
medina islam you know they acted on
their
belief and not american foreign policy
or
the israeli-palestinian question these
guys were driven
by the desire to do what is right
according to their islamic
beliefs according to the quran according
to the prophet muhammad
that got me into trouble number one and
obviously having said that and written
that
i had to reflect on my own religious
beliefs i was raised as a muslim
and up until that time i still
identified as a muslim
but i really started to have doubts
about
whether i believed in the moral system
that was um inherited from
the prophet muhammad and my conclusion
for me was i don't believe in that
anymore i don't believe that
the quran is the word of god it's
a document written by human beings and
obviously that's the greatest
[Music]
sin that you can commit as a muslim
and it's not just that you're committing
blasphemy but you're leaving the
religion
and in many muslim countries that's it's
a capital offense
but aside from what a government may do
there are also individuals
who are committed to the medina message
of islam
who then started to threaten me and
decided to take matters into their hands
i made a film
with theo van gaal who was one of the
well-known publicists in the netherlands
and a filmmaker
and i had protection at the time
provided for by the government of the
netherlands
he did not and he was shot
stabbed beheaded and they left this
big note for me uh on his body
and again the man who killed theo van
gaal still in prison
when he came to trial he made it very
clear
that he was motivated by his islamic
faith
not discrimination against him
not theo van gaal's insulting him as a
person
but he said he was motivated by his
religion
and the fact that making the film and
comments that theo fungal had made about
the prophet muhammad
were blasphemous and that that needed to
be punished
with death so why is it do you think
that the west
seems so ripe for the picking when it
comes to some of this stuff the very
fact that you make these points is very
controversial
in western countries mainly because
there's a wide
variety of people who have bought into a
line of thought that says that to even
talk about this stuff is in and of
itself offensive makes the situation
worse that the west is really the
creator of the situation in the first
place that the west is the great
oppressor
in all this what is the mindset of the
west that makes it uniquely vulnerable
to to these sorts of behaviors in the
sense that it won't defend itself
against
against cultures that obviously despise
it so
radical islam and terrorist attacks that
take place or that are plotted are
unfolding in a context within western
society
where there is a great deal of moral
relativism
we're in the midst of these culture wars
where on one side
identity politics prevails and according
to the dictates of identity politics
multiculturalism moral relativism
the west is held responsible for
past sins from slavery to colonialism to
the holocaust
and the story of western civilization is
solved
only from that perspective just
you know a series of terrible things
heinous offenses against humanity
that western civilization committed the
other side of the story
all the good things that the west has
done that is not told or it is
suppressed
and in that context it becomes you know
you
open the door for exploitation and the
radical islamists who are pushing
their political agenda through peaceful
means called dawa or through violence
called jihad
they exploit that opening and by the way
it's not just
radical islamists both china and russia
and other adversaries are happy to
exploit that sort of thing but again
ben you are absolutely right to pose
that question because
it's i don't think that radical islamic
doctrine
or its agenda is capable of defeating
western society it's just
militarily economically not
capable of doing that but if the west
implodes that's going to come from the
inside that does raise the question that
i
you know hear very often and is very
often expressed which is
why is it that there seems to be almost
a common cause between
left-wing identitarians you know people
who consider themselves to be feminists
and in favor of transgender rights or
gay rights
and radical muslims why why isn't there
a rift
in that particular coalition the
coalition makes no sense you have people
who
consider themselves defenders of women
rights will get who will get extremely
offended
anytime statistics like the one you
mentioned in your book are mentioned
you'll have defenders of gay rights who
suggest that muslim
crimes that take place or crimes by
radical muslims in in western societies
are the fault of the west even if those
crimes target
women and and gay people so why is that
coalition even even
not only you know durable why is it
ascendant it's because we don't
challenge
where these two movements these two
ideologies
um where they pathways so they have a
lot of things in common
the identitarians these days we call
them
woke so the woke
despise anyone who disagrees with them
they're committed to their orthodoxy
they use that same playbook of smearing
people's characters committing character
assassination and doing anything up they
can absolutely
to shut down debate and their political
agenda in many ways is similar to that
of the radical islam is because they
want to
bring the house down they complain that
there is structural racism
and structural injustice and the only
way to correct those injustices
is by bringing down the master's house
and that is a commitment that they share
with the radical islamists so you can
see where they come together and
work together but very few people have
taken
the opportunity to actually challenge
them on those issues because
radical islamists as you know
see women as inferior radical islamists
i don't think they've even recognized
that there's such a thing as
transgender and then
in many muslim countries and according
to radical islamists
uh homosexuals lgbt people
uh actually that's a capital offense and
they should be killed or imprisoned
and so no one has really taken them
the islamists and the identity politics
people
and put them in a place that
makes it very clear to them those two
groups
that there is some things they have in
common but there are
some pretty major things that they don't
i've seen a few incidents for instance
in the united kingdom
in some elementary or high school
situations where
sex education is recommended or demanded
by these schools and then the islamists
come in and shut that down
or where they try to make a case for
tolerance towards lgbt
communities and the islamists come down
they come and they shut that down
so i've seen incidents like that and
obviously i think you're familiar with
the history of iran
where a leftist movement was very happy
with
overthrowing the shah but they didn't
expect the islamists to take control and
when the islamists
took control of government they
obviously suppressed and shut down the
leftists threw them in prison and
executed them
and so for the moment i think uh
in that relationship or so-called
alliance between
the far left and the islamists
the islamists see the far left as useful
idiots
which they are and have been for a long
time so in a second i want to ask you
about how
various governments have essentially
been participating in a rather
widespread cover-up of the extent of the
problem
when it comes to criminal activity by
radical muslims in their society we'll
get to that in just a second but first
you know i don't get enough sleep but
when the alarm goes off i feel so much
more rested than i otherwise would
because i have a magical
made for me helix sleep mattress here's
the thing about helix sleep they
personalize a mattress for you
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect
mattress for you why would you buy a
mattress made for somebody else with
helix you're getting a mattress you know
will be perfect for the way you sleep
everybody's unique helix knows that they
have several different mattress models
to choose from they've got soft medium
firm mattresses mattresses that are
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks it's been awesome getting on so
many unboxing videos from so many of you
who also found that magical helix
mattress of your dreams
so if you are looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
your match to mattress comes right to
your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again helix is
awesome
don't take my word for it helix was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick
of 2020 by gq and wired magazine so head
on over to helix sleep.com
ben take that magical two minute sleep
quiz they will match you to a customized
mattress that'll give you the best sleep
of your life
got a 10 year warranty get to try it out
for 100 nights risk-free so what the
heck are you waiting for they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but i promise you will helix is offering
up to 200 bucks off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helixsleep.com
let's talk for a second about what
governments have been doing in order to
cover up the impact of some of the lack
of assimilation that's been happening
in europe because it turns out that as
you report medina muslims are having a
lot of trouble assimilating into
european values because there's a
fundamental disconnect there but
governments seem to have an interest
right now in covering up that
fundamental disconnect
that's right so most of these european
governments are made up
of coalitions usually and what you find
is that
parties political parties on the center
left
and some of them even far left are
convinced
that any kind of social cultural
criticism
is going to exacerbate racism and
stigmatize
muslim minorities and so they want to
steer
clear of any or any social
cultural factors that leaves the central
rights
parties with again the accusations
that they are bigoted and uh
racist and xenophobic and anti-immigrant
and so for decades there's been that
gridlock where almost nothing moves when
it comes to
things that the established parties
should be doing what i see in the
subject of prey
for instance this molestation of women
and making the public
space unsafe for women
that that is covered up using the exact
same rulebook
of you know if we talk about these
things if it comes to the open
these minorities are going to be
stigmatized
but they are stigmatized anyway radical
populist right-wing parties are growing
very quickly
and are becoming very powerful because
voters have
almost nowhere else to go and the
radical islamists who are well
established in some of these countries
are also becoming stronger and so this
whole argument
that we need to be politically correct
and we need to cover up
in order to avoid stigmatizing muslim
minorities
is it's just not working it's been
counterproductive
a lot of the statistics seem pretty hard
to come by what is the extent of the
problem with regards to crime increases
uh and how does that correlate with the
increase in populations of medina
muslims as you call them
so because of this cover-up some of
these governments
will not tell you they just either they
don't collect the data
or if they do they don't make the data
public so countries like
france germany the uk
some of these larger countries they just
say you know sexual violence is a
universal thing
it happens everywhere there's really
nothing specific
to some of these minority groups
especially
muslim communities but there are
countries who are different and who have
started to collect
data at least by noting down the
nationality or
the immigration status of the
individuals involved
one example is denmark another example
is austria
and there you see really not just an
explosion in terms of the offenses
committed against women in the public
space by people they don't know
but that in the case of austria for
instance
muslim immigrants are less than one
percent or asylum seekers i'm talking
about the last wave of 2015.
they're less than one percent of the
population but are responsible for
i think in the year 2017 it was 11
percent of offenses
that in 2018 jumped up to nearly 55
percent
of sexual offenses i mean think about
that
and similar stats in in denmark
and and then it really becomes
impossible to cover up
and so countries like austria have
spoken of a
rape epidemic they
they've become more open and they have
developed programs of
integrating or trying to assimilate
these young men
into society aside from you know
prosecutions
and convictions same thing in denmark
and so what you see is
the countries that bring these problems
into the open
and deal with it there is
more social cohesion less antagonism
towards immigrants
and there is a sense that voters can
trust their governments because their
governments are really dealing with the
problem
as opposed to the other countries that
try to um
to mask it and sweep everything under
the carpet
even some of the situations that become
widely known are absolutely shocking
obviously the one that comes to mind is
the situation rotherhad in england
in which there was an actual grooming
cell in which medina muslims were
essentially grooming
children underage people for sexual
activity and that appears to have been
covered up by the authorities
absolutely because the authorities were
terrified that they would be called
racists but what these pakistan
the young men who were involved were of
pakistani origin and yes they had
created
sort of almost a family syndicates
criminal syndicates
to prey on
underage girls but they were choosing
these underage girls
based on their skin color so that was a
really racist act
in itself they wouldn't go after muslim
girls because there would be
repercussions of course
and most muslim girls most of them are
kept inside and
their movements are controlled so it's
way more difficult for them to go after
immigrant girls
but they were going after these girls
and committing some of the most
atrocious
crimes against them and the british
government allowed
this to go on and on and on for years
and not just in rotherham it happened in
telford it happened in oxford it
happened in all sorts of other places
these children were betrayed the crimes
continued
the men who were committing the crimes
felt that they could get away with it
and there was this buzz that it's
something you can do
with no consequences and the government
the british government
failed to protect these children for
fear of being called racists
and the accusations of racism haven't
abated and they won't
one of the things that i think has been
most amazing to watch and it's happening
now in the united states as well which
we want to get to in a second
right is the we've talked about briefly
the unwillingness of the authorities
to defend the individual rights of their
citizens in the face of the possibility
they may actually be
called racist we saw this you know most
obviously
in the charlotte killings uh after the
the murder of a bunch of staffers at the
french satirical magazine
there is this initial outburst of
support from members of the left saying
we are all
charlie hebdo i wonder if that would
happen today i wonder if there were a
massacre at a magazine
targeted by radical islamists who were
doing so on the basis of having been
offended by cartoons
whether they wouldn't instead be a
stronger counter movement there was at
the time too
a stronger counter movement suggesting
that there needed to be some sort of
curtailment of freedom of speech those
to provide
a in a bulwark against offensiveness
well
the movement to curtail free speech is
alive and well and it's been growing and
again the islamists have been exploiting
it bringing in the word islamophobia and
lobbying
for all sorts of legislation against
so-called hate crimes
and that's just an attempt to shut up
decent and serious debate on these
issues
but if you look at the situation in
france so for decades we were told
don't talk about these issues because
it's going to empower the far right
well the far right is empowered maria le
pen's front national party is now the
second largest party
and the po according to the polls in the
previous relations
in the previous election there was a
chance that she could have won the
presidency
and in the coming elections of next year
there is again an even bigger chance
that she she can win those elections and
become the president of france so the
argument
that the extreme right wing is going to
grow is just
false or only grows if you put a taboo
on these issues aside from that
the current president who is i would say
squarely in the center
has said that we have a very big problem
in france
where a large number of the population
is separating itself
from the rest of france led by radical
islamists to reject
all things french the laws
the norms the values and
a problem that in my view you know about
30 years ago
was smallish and could have been
prevented
is now this entrenched issue
where even though they are passing
legislation
to mitigate that separatism uh
abolishing homeschooling and demanding
all sorts of things
to ensure that that separates these
ghettos
don't break away it's still in my view
too little too late but it makes the
argument
that making things taboo and legislating
hate speech is not going to take the
problem away
so in a second i want to ask you about
your experiences in the united states
trying to speak on college campuses
trying to speak freely we'll get to that
in just one moment first let's talk
about how you can save money
and time by not going to the post office
the post office great place but
you can spend an awful lot of time there
waiting in line and then having to deal
with the person behind the counter and
all that
taking trips to the post office is
probably not how you actually want to
spend your time that's why i recommend
mailing and shipping online
at stamps.com stamps.com allows you to
mail and ship anytime anywhere right
from your computer send letters ship
packages
pay a lot less with discounted rates
from usps ups
and more stamps.com to save businesses
thousands of hours
tons of money with stamps.com you get
all the services of the postal service
and ups
all in one place here at dailywear don't
waste our time or money we've been using
stamps.com since 2017
stamps.com brings the services of the us
postal service and ups directly
to your computer simply use your
computer to print official us postage
24 7 for any letter any package any
class email anywhere you want to send it
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pickup or drop it off
with stamps.com you get discounts of up
to 40 off post office rates up to 62
off ups shipping rates stamps.com saving
you time saving your money stop wasting
your time going to the post office go to
stamps.com instead
no risk with my promo code shapiro you
get a special offer it includes a four
week trial plus free postage and digital
scale
no long-term commitments no contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
type in shapiro that is stamps.com
promo code shapirostamps.com never go to
the post office again
alrighty so let's talk about your
experience on american college campuses
because it does speak to something that
is sort of broader that's been happening
in the west and it is not
specifically governmental policy driven
because governmental policy is usually
downstream of of culture
we now seem to be a culture that values
a sense of offense
that that values victimization uh that
that
values the feelings of people more than
it does the rights
of of individuals and obviously this is
applied to you
uh i remember when you were essentially
barred from speaking at brandeis
university for the great crime of being
an alleged islamophobe how prevalent do
you think
this ideology is on campus then how far
do you think that that has spread into
american society more broadly
i think it is very concerning
maybe even alarming that
um in the united states and across
western society we have a growing group
of people
who subscribe to this ideology
of they call it
critical justice theory or critical race
theory
again i think the general public just
calls it woke because that's what they
call themselves
but in this ideology yes it's all about
uh feelings it's about
subjectivity there is no universal truth
and like we spoke about earlier
they do hate america and
western civilization not just the
terrible things that we did in the past
but even the good things we're all
racists
uh we're islamophobes we're transphobes
we're
this phobic and that phobic and there's
just there's a rejection
by the people who subscribe to this
ideology of having
any kind of objective truth
where we can agree on what exactly
racism is
so that we can all fight it or what
exactly you know homophobia transphobia
islamophobia
what these things are so that we can
fight it there is a corruption of
language
there is a corruption of the curriculum
of
middle school high school colleges and i
don't think this is going to end well if
we carry on this way because
in my view that is how the closing of
minds
takes place we're basically closing the
minds of young people
people now in college and the reason why
they don't want me to come and speak in
some of these colleges
or the reason why they don't want you to
go and speak in these colleges
is because you are going to violate
their safe spaces
we are accused of microaggressions
i've been doing this book promotion that
is really about women's rights
and women's magazines will not respond
won't have me
because some of the employees might not
feel safe
so it's getting pretty ridiculous and
i think four or five years ago i used to
laugh it off
and now watching people being cancelled
people losing their livelihoods
people in academic life
saying you know i wanted to do research
on this topic but i don't think i'm
going to do it anymore because i don't
want to deal with the trouble
that that's going to cause me so this is
now getting not just
into free speech it's going getting into
academic freedom
it is a hostility to science it's a
hostility to
the constitution which we all think is
in my view the best document
ever devised the best political document
ever devised
so i i'm more than concerned i think
it's alarming
and um i hope that people now
wake up and understand that it's not
just something that you can
let it's uh you know let it just happen
it's a fad it's going to blow
it won't it's getting worse and worse it
does seem like it's getting worse and
worse and i think a lot of that has to
do with just
an insane amount of ingratitude by
people who have grown up in in this
society i think one of the the
great problems with growing up in a
prosperous society where
essentially you can expect that when you
are born you're going to live
80 long years minimum and that you're
going to be able to go to
a good school that you'll if you work
hard you'll be able to go to college
you'll be able to get a job you'll be
able to live whatever sexual lifestyle
you want
is that you tend to think that these
things are the natural state of human
kind you tend to think that that that is
all natural
and that all the bad stuff that's unique
to your society and so when something
bad happens in society
you immediately look at society as as
the problem it's our system
that is the problem whereas it seems to
me that if you've had any sort of
outside view of any country other than
the united states you can quickly see
that actually all the wonderful things
about the united states and about the
westmore generally
are not the natural state of mankind
they're quite unnatural and they took a
while to develop and stripping away the
central premises
of these societies is likely to lead to
a complete collapse
absolutely and i think if young people
growing up in america or in any other
western society if they feel
that their societies are unjust and
terrible places to live in
i think the best program would be for
them to spend some time
in other countries where life is
different
so some of the women who say oh my gosh
it's terrible to be a woman in the
united states
i would say spend a few months in
afghanistan or
in any country in the middle east
try and take some time off and go to
various parts of africa
and let's see what you come back with go
find a place that's actually better than
where you live
where the laws are better the values are
better the norms are better
and and then report back and i think if
it were
you know an integrated part of the
college curriculum
or a gap year after you leave high
school i think people would come back
really sober and appreciative of what
they have
and definitely ben you know we've got to
improve
on the situation in america we have
inequality we have
injustices we have uh racism we have
all of these problems none of us are
denying that
it's just that a the answer is not to
destroy the entire
framework and the entire structure of
american society
and b there are ways of doing it within
the system the ways of
trying to achieve
improvements within the system we have
rather than argue uh and
advocate for the complete destruction of
what we have
it does seem like it's an ideological
revolution versus people who actually
want to effectuate change if you want to
effectuate change
and you see a problem then i've said
this many times
you know throughout my career if you
name a problem with great specificity
and you provide the data to back up that
it is indeed a problem that is curable
then it's going to be very easy to
mobilize people on the side of that cure
as a general rule
what makes it very difficult is when
people throw out these semantically
overloaded terms
and and these bizarre sort of
sloganeering phrases
and then suggest that the solution is to
overturn the entire system and when you
provide data to suggest that maybe the
problem is not what they are saying the
problem is
then you are castigated for obviously
not being aware of your own internalized
racism at a certain point this does
reach
cult levels and and these sort of
anti-racist movements in the united
states particularly seems to be
at this point occult when you have
people like abram kennedy saying things
like you denying that you are racist is
proof that you are a racist that is the
same thing as witchburning
absolutely so this and ibrahim candy
robin de angelo who wrote white
fragility
uh they are absolutely not interested in
debate they are not interested in
discussion in my view they are not even
interested in ending racism because they
refuse to define it
ibrahim kennedy goes from refining it as
something that affects people to not
it's not about people he said
it's about policies and then you have
this jump uh
from one to the other again this
corruption of language
is circular reasoning uh you are white
therefore you're racist if you say i'm
not then you are
suffering from white fragility and so
round and round we go
and that has a cult-like quality to it
and it also has a cult-like
following to it and if i look at some of
the people who
who animated by this these are
middle-class
young white people mostly young white
people
it's not they're not many hispanics or
african-americans or other immigrants
from other parts of the world
who are drawn to this cult
and walk ideology it's mainly white
middle-class people
some you know i'm not an expert i'm not
a sociologist or a psychologist
or a psychiatrist but someone really
needs to try and explain why this is the
case um
and again i've tried to look at
black lives matter as an organization as
a movement i've been on the website
just curious because in the summer we
had the killing of george floyd
a terrible incident and i go on their
website
and i don't find anything on that
website and in their message
that i would say would improve the lives
of black people right now
there are things in there such as the
abolition of the nuclear family
now if you really care about the
african-american community
one thing you would not do would be to
suggest that the nuclear
family be abolished because one of the
huge problems we have
is these absent fathers teenage
pregnancies
there is that type of social blight
where
the first step would be actually to
advocate for
the nuclear family they're advocating
for reparations
this is so cosmic and abstract it's not
something
that an african-american kid in texas or
in chicago or in new york is going to
feel like that changes
my situation right now they're against
charter schools they're against the
police they want to
defund the police so you have to ask
yourself
why is this huge contradiction if it's
really
if they really really care about black
people
then why are they advocating for all the
things that would ruin
black families and black communities the
answer is
they're not interested in black
communities they're interested in
getting to power by
exploiting vulnerable communities like
blacks like transgender communities
like women and so on and so forth so
these are not people it's not an
ideology or a cult
that's interested in justice or bringing
about justice it's only
for them to get power and i think it
really is about power dynamics in a
second i want to ask you about the
formation of what i think is really a
new ruling class in the united states
first
let's talk about the need for life
insurance here's the thing when you shop
online you save time you save money
so why exactly would you buy life
insurance by like asking your friend
instead why not go online and save time
and money with our friends over at
policy genius
policy genius can help you compare top
insurers in one place save 50
or more once you find your best option
the policy genius team will help you
set up your new policy for you and
answer any questions you have along the
way
here's how you can get started first
head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need
and you can compare quotes to find your
best price policy genius makes it easy
to compare policies from as little as 15
bucks a month
you might even be eligible to skip that
in-person medical exam since their
licensed agents work for you not the
insurance companies there's no hassle if
you hit any speed bumps during the
application process
policy genius will take care of
everything for you that kind of service
has earned policy genius a five-star
rating
across thousands of reviews on
trustpilot and google the best part
all the benefits of policy genius the
comparison tool handling of paperwork
unbiased advice
totally free to use you got to protect
the people
who rely on you life insurance is
something that every responsible adult
should have so
while you are tidying up around the
house this spring get your life
insurance organized as well you could
say 50
or more by comparing quotes feel good
knowing if something happens your loved
ones will be taken care of go to
policygenius.com right now to get
started
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and very important to get it
right
so one of the things i on that that i've
been talking about a lot these days
is the renormalization of america this
idea that if you have an intransigent
minority that you can completely
renormalize institutions from the inside
it's something that
nicholas talib has talked about this
this idea that it only takes a small
coterie of people to re-normalize an
entire institution all you need
is a bunch of people in the middle who
are willing to say nothing and a a small
group of very entrant people
who are willing to push as hard as
humanly possible when you do that you
can renormalize institutions and you can
then institute a gatekeeping protocol
whereby if people don't mirror your
language they're just not allowed to be
part of the new ruling class it seems to
me that so much
of what we are talking about right now
is in fact about that it's about people
knowing what words to say you go to
college these days not to actually learn
a skill set or to
learn how to do a job you learn to use
the sort of language that you need to
use in order to get ahead and this means
putting pronouns in your twitter bio and
it means using the term of tanks as
opposed to latino
and it means posting a black square on
your instagram page in the middle of the
black lives matter protest
and none of this is really about
improving individual lives a lot more of
it has to do with
claiming membership in a sort of
non-secret society of people who are in
the know about the evils of the american
system
that's exactly why i use the word
alarming and why i said in
you know a few years ago we were all
amused by it and now it's not amusing
it's alarming
yes there is a small it's a it's a small
group but it is intransigent
they're determined and they've
frightened
most other people into silence or
acquiescence
or just looking away and pretending
there's nothing going on
while they take control of institutions
and that
is why i said it's alarming that's
precisely what we've seen
in societies that were infiltrated
by such tiny groups such as radical
islamists
you know when i talk to some of my arab
friends they say
you know things were more modern and
more liberal and more relaxed and more
tolerant
in the 50s and 1960s and in the 70s than
they are today
and that is because that small minority
of islamists
incredibly determined were able to get
what they wanted
and take over institutions because they
were able to frighten
the masses they were able to frighten
the middle classes they were able to
frighten
corporations and leaders into either
towing
their line or staying silent and letting
things happen
and that's exactly why i use the word
alarming
that even though these woke people um
the language they use the demands that
they make are outrageous they're
ridiculous
and sometimes we think uh they're funny
but
it's not funny um and and
i think it's time we actually wake up so
aion you've joined a new group
called the foundation against
intolerance and racism it has a wide
variety of people from
all sides of the political aisle mainly
they seem to be sort of from the
classical
liberal category people who wouldn't
consider themselves republicans in
american politics
um probably would vote democrat overall
if they were just aligning with a
particular
you know governmental ideology but who
are rejecting
the woke you know it seems to me that
this is the only
possibility for saving the west is is
not on the right the right
believes what the right believes and we
on you know i consider myself obviously
a conservative
we who are openly conservative have long
held out against the sort of predations
of the the radical woke left
and the multicultural ethos they've been
pushing but there are a lot of folks
who are who are liberal in the sense
that they are sort of for bigger
government they want nationalized health
care they want higher taxes more
redistributionism
um but also used to be defenders of
individual rights and that group seems
to be splitting almost directly down the
middle
there are some people who are who are
liberal who
are you know signing harper's weekly
letters and joining the foundation
against intolerance and racism
and then there are other liberals who've
decided to go along with the woke
because the woke have many of the same
political priorities they do so that
that's exactly
so i did join fair and uh i think
fair as an organization is deliberately
made up
of people of different political
affiliations
uh left right center
because all of us who really understand
what the work ideology is about
also understand that they don't care the
work
do not care whether you are center-left
or center-right
they want to bring the entire structure
down now it's also true
that this work ideology has come out of
the left side of things and so
number one i think it's people on the
left
you know i i call them
the same left or the liberal left
they have to wake up to the fact that
the democratic party but also other
liberal institutions have made
themselves
vulnerable to what this toxic
ideology of walkism
on the conservative side i think that
it's not enough to be you know to be
apathetic and say well that's happening
to them it's not happening to me it's
happening to all of us
so it is an alliance we all have to form
i think for a long time
at least since 1945 we truly understand
what white supremacy and far-right
ideologies
mean and what they can lead to
and it's a message that we need to
continue
to propagate teach younger generations
don't be don't be lured don't be seduced
by the ideology of white supremacists on
the far right
but we've paid very very little
attention to some of the
you know far-left ideology or ideologies
that
are cropping up there because we've
always thought that whatever comes of
the left is something that can be
excused or tolerated or it's just a
fringe
people will get over it it's romantic
and it just isn't and now we're being
confronted
with this 90 1984 type
you know orwellian dystopia that they're
chasing and that
in some communities it seems as if
they've achieved those things
i mean the social pressure is so bad
barry weiss who i know are both friendly
with printed a piece uh
over the past few weeks uh in which she
interviewed parents of students who are
going to
very highfaluting private schools a
place like harvard west lake in la where
i grew up which was widely known as the
best
uh private high school in in that part
of the country
and and parents are scared to speak up
they are scared to tell their kids
truths hard truths about individual
responsibility because they're afraid
they're going to be
called out for it lose their livelihoods
this way uh i wonder ion if you think
that society
can actually hold this way dude is there
going to be a breaking point here
uh is is it seems to me that there is no
possibility that the woke in the end
actually win and maintain the country as
it is because that would require actual
tyranny would require
actual top-down dominance uh but that
doesn't mean that the country will hold
well we need a million barry wises and
pizza bargosians and james lindsey's and
helen place roses and you know these
individuals who themselves were seared
by the consequences of this ideology
and barry weiss herself actually lost
her livelihood
she was had her career in the new york
times and describes and it's chilling to
see what is going on inside that
newsroom and how
they're going to bring this thing down
if you look at the small
subsets of places where the woke have
taken over
that tyranny is omnipresent people
can't they can't express themselves
and they can't criticize they can't
weigh in on
whatever the institution is doing that
they don't agree with
now we have unanimous letters sorry
anonymous letters people writing letters
saying you know i subscribed to this
ideology i thought i was a part of this
movement
and now i regret that and then they
describe the internal workings of that
tyranny but they won't put their name on
their work
because they know the consequences are
dire
and so what seeing that
now uh in a relatively small
you know small institution small places
why would we want that to take over the
entire country
so in a second i want to ask you about
what's the best way to to fight back
against some of this stuff because some
of us are in the awareness racing
business but
it seems like if there are no
institutions that mirror the awareness
and they're not
moving so it's a fight back against
wokism that we may be sort of spitting
into the wind a little bit
guess that in just one second first
let's talk about how to make your
company better and more efficient
here's the reality if your business
isn't growing it's dying which is why
your business needs to grow and the only
way your business
can keep growing is if you have the best
employees and that is why we here at
daily wire use
zip recruiter zipper is indeed the way
to go right now
you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com ben guest
zip recruiter doesn't wait for great
candidates to find you zip recruiter
finds them
for you when you post a job on zip
recruiter it gets sent out to over 100
top job sites with one click
to increase your chances of reaching top
talent then zip recruiter's powerful
matching technology scans thousands of
resumes to find people with the right
skills and experience for your job and
actively invites them to apply so you
get qualified candidates super fast
no wonder four out of five employers who
post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within
the very first day if you're a company
and you need a better employee or if
you're an employee you're looking for a
great company
ziprecruiter is the best way to do it
start finding great candidates today
when you try zip recruiter for free just
go to this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com ben guest once again
that is ziprecruiter.com
b-e-n-g-u-e-s-t zip recruiters dot com
zip recruiter is the smartest way to
hire all right so let's talk about
how we fight back against this because
one of the things that i found is that
when when i talk with people who
are typically you know democrat voters
fairly open-minded if you talk to them
about this they will acknowledge that
all of this is true behind closed doors
but then the minute that they step out
from behind closed doors they will
immediately start mirroring the
priorities of the woke
i mean i i know that uh you and i have
actually both been in rooms
where there are people who are saying
things behind closed doors that you and
i actually
fairly strongly agree with and then the
minute that those doors
open and suddenly the cameras are let in
they are just saying exactly what they
know
they're supposed to say in order to get
ahead how do you cure that how do how do
we
fight back against this so i think there
is the awareness aspect which we've
covered
um i think there is the legislation
aspects uh
i think one of the last acts of uh the
trump administration was to say
we're not going to allow the spread of
the critical theory critical race
critical justice propaganda
in federal government and we are not
going to pay for that with taxpayer
money
so there's that kind of big tool that
you need
i think we also need to use tools such
as litigation
uh america's after all a country where
uh
if we disagree we take things to the
courts and
allow the courts to decide i mean some
of the for instance barry wise being
called a nazi
by her colleagues why is that not
workplace harassment
and if people are afraid of losing their
livelihoods because they're being called
racists or they're being
forced to take unconscious bias classes
that is something that i think is at
this stage
right for litigation if those who are
making the accusation
cannot prove the charges of racism and
other bigotry and and these charges as
you've seen
with your friends and mine too
they do lead people to have all sorts of
psychological and mental health problems
uh i wouldn't want to be accused of
racism it's terrible
then imagine your colleagues doing that
and your colleagues ostracizing you
and being demoted i've heard of college
students who say
this isn't the paper that i wanted to
write i wrote this paper with this
content because if i write what i
exactly feel about a certain topic
i'm going to get a c or a d or an f if i
want to get an
a then i have to produce a walk paper
can you imagine that level of corruption
and so the pushback would be
to use every peaceful tool possible
that we have we have in our toolbox
and as the problem gets bigger and as
more and more people become
aware of it i think those tools are
going to be used
so it seems like right now one of the
things that's happening is that we have
a battle
on on the right against people who are
you know reactionary reacting solely to
the woke they're more anti-left than
they are
in favor of necessarily individual
rights and that seems like at least a
minority movement
on the right then you have the woke on
the left and so i guess the broader
question
that i have for you aion is you know is
this just an inherent weakness of
secular societies
uh because classical liberalism yeah the
the founding fathers of the united
states originally assumed the classical
liberalism and individual
rights rested on a certain
judeo-christian moral foundation
right and and that as that disintegrated
that eventually it would just become
competition among individuals for power
and who could grab the levers of power
and then use those levers of power
against one another then if there was no
social cohesion
on any basis uh other than you know
a sort of a sort of waspish atomistic
libertarianism
uh that that would that would eventually
come apart do you think that that's true
do you think that a secular society
can preserve itself in the face of what
appear to be
you know cult-like threats from the woke
which is essentially a religious threat
from the woke or in the face of an
intransigent radical
islam in particular situations is
secularism just you know bound to be
torn apart by sort of more adamant and
more radical ideologies
i think the the saying you know that if
you want to preserve
liberty it's an eternal struggle it is
something that you have to be aware of
all the time that holds true to this day
and whether a society is secular or not
if a society is
free and if the fundamental
principle of that society is based on
freedom and
liberty then the assumption is that that
eternal vigilance
is warranted i think bad ideas
and bad ideologies are just part of
being human
we were dealing with radical islamic
ideology and still are to a certain
extent
and then up comes this work ideology
that is sort of a
recycled marxism or neo-marxism which we
are familiar with
is it easier for these ideologies
especially the quasi-religious types of
things
to emerge and find a foothold
in secular societies i think the answer
to that is true
that if you have your own religion
judaism or christianity or whatever you
have your own
belief community it becomes difficult
for other people
to seduce you with
ideologies you know you think i've
already got a religion i don't need your
religion
you also if you i think come up come out
of a religious background
as i do you recognize a religion when
you see it's
you know occult
and that cultish characteristics of
the walk um i think anybody who's grown
up in any serious religion
can see that this this is a religious
quasi-religious
thing but i i'm very careful because i'm
not an expert on this topic but i do
listen to both sides
i want to be very careful that
i don't say oh the solution to the
problem we're having right now is
because we've drifted away from religion
we have to go back to religions
i think that's first of all not possible
but even if it were possible
i think walkism and other by
other bad ideologies will emerge anyway
and so i prefer to go back to that
that truth truism that if you want to
preserve
a liberal society you do have to do it
with which it's
constant vigilance you just can't get
complacent unfortunately so ayan i want
to ask you also about the
the sort of institutions that have been
cramming this down we've talked a lot
about various governments that have been
cramming this down
universities uh one of the gravest
threats that we've
touched on but i want to get your take
on it more broadly is the corporate
threat to freedom that as we
have more and more our our rights uh
available made available uh through
giant corporations the
the social media companies the amazons
of the world
that does make it very easy for a few
people who are badly motivated or scared
into doing bad things to simply hit a
delete button and suddenly restrict our
ability to
to use our rights is there a way to curb
that
how big is the threat that we should be
looking at when it comes to for example
social media or amazon
digitally book burning abigail
schreier's book or ryan
anderson's book or things like that so
the big tech
issue big tech monopolies um i
i have a friend vivek uh ramaswamy who
says
back in the day when we talked about
monopolies it was price fixing
that we had to worry about and today in
the 21st century
what we have to worry about is idea
fixing
so i mean i'm not an economist but
superficially
what we all know is that
a monopoly is really bad for consumers
and
aside from anti-trust laws and again i
can't get into the ins and outs of that
because i don't know very much about it
but i think having monopolies is a bad
thing
what we need is market competition
and i'm very reluctant to have the
government
involved in coming in as the rescuer
because as you and i know what the
government does it already does terribly
and so giving them more powers
especially on issues of free speech that
worries me a bit
but i think what you and i also agree on
is a private company can do whatever a
private company wants to
if they want to ban a book they can ban
a book the answer
has to be in market competition and i
think that
curtailing of competition that that
is the real problem and that's something
that has to be looked into
um because again my book is published by
harpercollins
but others have refused to do it and the
reasons that they gave me for that is
you know they were afraid of islamist
threats they were afraid of this that
and the other
but as long as you go you can go
somewhere else you can go to another
vendor
um then there is no problem
but we have a problem now because we
have these four or five big
companies and it's difficult for
something else to come up
uh that is a problem do you think that
the tide is going to turn here is there
going to be a backlash i mean obviously
we've seen a sort of populist backlash
in europe but i'm not sure that's the
kind of backlash any of us are really
looking for specifically uh we have seen
a backlash here i think
what led to the election of donald trump
in 2016 was a backlash against
at the time i don't remember we used the
word walking but the prevailing phrase
was
political correctness so if
you know a free populations if if we
feel like we we can't speak
we can't say what we need to say and
we're called deplorables and looked down
upon
then people uh will vote
with their feet they leave the parties
that are calling them these names
one thing that gives me hope is the
emergence
of podcasts uh
sub stack you know all of these
market-driven
ways of exchanging information
that established organizations
refuse to publish so instead of me
having to call the new york times all
the time can you please publish this au
pair
now we're starting our own podcasts our
own newsletters we're blogging
we are communicating with one another
using the market forces
to communicate information
and opinion that is censored
away from other places i hope that that
can that is the true
backlash and i've heard and read about
people who are
saying maybe podcasts should also be
stopped or controlled or restrained or
you know and again let's be aware of
that and let's push back against that
the only when we say you know vigilance
freedom needs constant vigilance it also
needs
the constant protection of the freedom
of speech
the freedom to exchange ideas without
fear
and here we are i mean we are not on any
of the
big powerful broadcasting corporations
uh
you've got your own thing and i've
started my own thing and all the people
we know
they've started their own thing and i
think there lies at least in terms of
increasing the awareness of problems i
think
there we have a solution and a proper
backlash
so i do want to ask you a few final
questions starting with how do you deal
with all the incoming because
there are very few people in the west
have experienced the kind of incoming
you've had to experience in terms of
being targeted
for violent threats and then just the
the amount of flack you've taken
if you'd like to hear ion hersey ellie's
answers however you have to be a daily
wire member
head on over to dailywire.com click
subscribe you can hear the rest of our
conversation over there
ryan hersey ellie it's an honor and a
pleasure to have you here on sunday
special really appreciate your time
ben thank you very very much for having
me that was wonderful
everyone make sure to go out and get a
copy of iyan's new book pray immigration
islam and the erosion of women's rights
ayan
thank you so much for joining the show
it's been an honor and a pleasure thank
you very much for having
[Music]
the me shapiro show sunday's special is
produced by mathis glover
executive producer jeremy boring our
technical director is austin stevens and
our assistant director is pavel wydowsky
associate producer nick sheehan our
guests are booked by caitlin maynard
editing is by jim nicholl audio is mixed
by mike coromina hair and makeup is by
fabiola cristina
title graphics are by cynthia angulo the
ben shapiro show sunday special is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
you